first new evidence tonight that we you
the American people all of us we were
all lied to we were lied to by the mob
and the media we were lied to by big
Tech we were lied to repeatedly by the
Democratic party we were lied to by Joe
Biden and the Biden family we were lied
to by our federal government and all of
it was an effort to elect Joe Biden and
defeat Donald Trump under Biden's laptop
from hell in fact was very real and the
report from the New York Post about that
laptop two weeks before the election in
2020 it was accurate and it was true now
Hunter's father remember the big guy
according to the emails in that laptop
is implicated in his son Shady
international business deals and now
both the Washington Post the New York
Times all of a sudden verify this
information of course there's no mystery
here this is a major massive cya
according to the Wall Street Journal the
criminal investigation and to Hunter
Biden is heating up and he could soon
face serious criminal charges so they
said uh oh we might be caught covering
up for the bidens again uh we better act
like we we reported on this story it
won't work in a moment we're going to
take a trip down memory lane we'll
review the biggest lies from America's
trusted institutions but first let's
take a moment to recap what they're
lying about now we begin with a little
background on Joe Biden's adult son
Hunter Biden Hunter obviously deeply
troubled man he has struggled with a
severe and often debilitating addiction
to crack cocaine and prostitutes he was
even discharged from the U.S military
because of his drug problem and because
of his lifestyle well his resume and
background or anything but pristine yet
for years zero experienced Hunter and a
shady business associates garnered
lucrative payouts from foreign Nationals
all over the world for example hunt to
received a whopping 3.5 million dollar
wire transfer from a Russian oligarch
the former first lady of Moscow he also
got five million dollars from a
state-backed Chinese company part of a
multi-billion dollar deal with the Bank
of China another hundred thousand
dollars plus for an international
shopping spree compliments of a
prominent Chinese National why doesn't
that happen to any of you and on top of
the 1.5 billion dollar deal with the
Bank of China that's a lot of money plus
you also got another 100 Grand plus from
a Kazakhstan oligarch earmarked for a
brand new sports car what a life he has
and let's not forget the 1.5 million
that he received sitting on the board of
Barista Holdings a massive Ukrainian oil
and gas conglomerate with ties to a
Russian oligarch now his company made
millions in that case Hunter had zero
experience in energy oil gas and no
experience with Ukraine and he had zero
experience with investing abroad at also
and still these Shady foreign Nationals
China Russia eastern Ukraine Eastern
Europe all making uh Hunter Biden the
Biden family Syndicate extremely rich
and by the way it's only the tip of the
iceberg stop for one second and pause
and ask yourself what if Hunter's name
was Trump anyway so why were these
wealthy foreigners sending a prostitute
loving crackhead why were they giving
him so much money because his dad was a
prominent Senator remember turn vice
president a lot of this happened when
Joe was vice president and the world
knew that Joe had presidential
aspirations now they were paying for
access to the highest levels of our
government and it appears they got it
Hunter even admitted this obvious fact
or in an interview with GMA which was an
unmitigated disaster and let's not
forget as Vice President Biden withheld
that billion tax taxpayer dollars in
loan guarantees from Ukraine you're not
getting the billion until you fire that
prosecutor think about this uh vice
president of our country saying fire a
prosecutor or you're not getting the
money and you have six hours and Son of
a b they did it they fired the
prosecutor turns out that prosecutor was
investigating zero experienced Hunter
and the company we was in business with
verisma for corruption in other words
there really was a quid pro quo in
Ukraine it was with Joe and even bragged
about it on camera but according to Joe
he never ever one time never ever ever
ever ever
spoke with his son about his business
deals ever just never came up take a
look
Mr Vice President how many times have
you ever spoken to your son about his
overseas business dealings I've never
spoken to my son about his overseas I
have never discussed with my son or my
brother or anyone else anything having
to do with their businesses period And
what I will do is the same thing we did
in our Administration there will be an
absolute wall between personal and
private uh and and the government do you
stand by your statement that you did not
discuss any of your son's overseas
business yes I stand by that statement
we all now know that is a flat out lie
we have evidence to prove it and not
only did Joe know about his son's
business partners he actually met with
them now here's Joe and Hunter they're
pictured with Hunter's favorite
Kazakhstan oligarch and here's Joe with
Hunter's uh Mexican business associates
uh but it gets worse well then Vice
President Joe Biden met with Hunters
Partners Hunter well he was paying
Daddy's bills and according to emails
and text messages on the laptop from
Hell Hunter acted like a bag man for the
entire Biden family Syndicate raking in
cash paying off all the bills clearly
this raises massive concerns about
whether or not your president the
president of the United States Joe Biden
was compromised now oh the media mob
weren't they interested if there was any
Trump Russia collusion that turned out
to be a big conspiracy theory lie why
aren't they interested in this now those
with Trump derangement syndrome they
didn't care it was so desperate to beat
Donald Trump they did their very best to
cover all of it up in October 2020
social media giant Twitter remember this
they locked the New York Post out of
their own account for daring to publish
the very true laptop story now Twitter
users they were also blocked from
sharing the report even in private
messages Facebook they censored the
report as well and two weeks before the
election more than 50 former U.S Intel
officials they signed a letter calling
the laptop story Russian disinformation
they had no reason to call it that they
were all lying and protecting Joe and
meanwhile NPR you helped pay for that
announced that they wouldn't waste their
time on the hunter Biden report because
it wasn't really a story it was Donald
Trump's Sons it would be a story one New
York Times article referring to the
report as farcical Russian
disinformation
Washington Post also suggested without
evidence it was part of some foreign
election disinformation scheme where's
their proof where's their evidence now
none of these media Outlets ever lifted
a finger to verif verify the laptop
until now a new report in the Washington
Post uh details what we've been telling
you now for nearly two years on this
program and that is zero experience
Hunter Biden got paid millions of
dollars from Chinese Nationals in return
for next to nothing with no expertise
other than a connection to his vice
president father at the time hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else